a grand welcome in mongolia's capital as
Pope Francis spent a second day in the
Buddhist Nation with one of the smallest
Roman Catholic communities in the world
in recent years Beijing has tightened
regulations against religious groups
that could challenge the Communist Party
and part of the sermon he gave an Ulan
Bator seemed to be aimed at China
governments and secure institutions have
nothing to fear from the church's work
of evangelization for it has no
political agenda to advance
but it is sustained by the quiet power
of God's grace and a message of mercy
and Truth which is meant to promote the
good of all
than 30 years after Mongolia sanctioned
freedom of worship less than 2 000
people are practicing Roman Catholics
some travel for their opportunity to see
the Pope
[Music]
we are from the kanul district church
called Maria we've been going to church
for 18 years we are about to see the
Holy Father and we waited this moment
for so many years
the Pope's visit to Mongolia Drew
Catholics from across the region
including people from China
we've always been looking forward to it
we really hope that gradually our
government and leaders will accept him
and invite him to visit our country that
would be the most joyful thing for us
Pope Francis stopped to wave in front of
the Statue of mongolia's founder Genghis
Khan calling himself a pilgrim of
friendship this five-day papal visit
aimed at bringing the church's message
to areas and people who sometimes felt
ignored by Rome
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera